this is quite straightforward in terms
of lights it's got less pieces in it
than the previous one um there's only
one thing you can factorize which is
what yeah just the numerator right so
you factorize it like so that's good the
bottom is just what it is okay so from
there I can read off the vertical a
sustain it the vertical asymptote is try
to be specific so we've got what's a
satisfying its of x equals 3 yeah x
equals 3 good and then comes this
question all ok well what's happening at
my edges what happens as X gets really
really enormous okay now in this case
there's an oblique asymptote and the
question is what is it so put your pens
down for a moment let's stop thinking
out the graph for a living
let's just think about this guy as a
function your x squared minus 1 and on
your divided by X minus 3 now we have
spent so much time feeding at these for
calculus and thinking about them as
graphs that we sometimes forget this is
just a division it's just the division
it's just not numbers you're dividing
its what are these things called
individually it starts with a pain deep
polynomials so if you're dividing
polynomials then surprise surprise maybe
it might be useful if I tried polynomial
division right Oh
groundbreaking right see he's not gonna
do I'm gonna divide these guys now at
the moment it's not clear why in your
mind but as soon as we finish I hope
you'll see one how do I divide these
things I'm gonna write my division
symbol what am I gonna write I can't
trap for young big beginners just like
if you divide a number like two hundred
and one by long division you write two
zero one you know right to minute one it
matters that there is none of them did
okay what about over here this is the
device I can stop me off
okay good now remember at this point
just like in numerical on division I'm
subtracting so these guys cancel and
this leaves me we have someone else take
over 3x now what now what am I writing
okay you multiply back which gives you I
cannot be careful swimming negatives
flying around but you're subtracting
here so minus one takeaway this gives
you okay
and then at this point you say I can't
fit any more X's in there so what does
this eight mean okay now what's the
point of doing this what's the point of
polynomial division well that means is
you can restate the original polynomial
as this times this plus that that's what
it means okay so I can rewrite x squared
minus one I don't have to rewrite it
like this I can write it differently I
can also write it as just like you told
me X minus three X plus three plus eight
that's x squared minus one is just
another way to write it all divided by X
minus three now when you compare this
versus this you're like oh I don't know
would you write it like this can you see
why what am I trying to find I'm trying
to find an oblique asymptote all right I
don't think asymptotes now let me try
and make it a little more obvious to you
this is two things on the top divided by
the same thing so I'm gonna write them
as two separate fractions do you agree I
can do that get you bring numerators hot
little group so what happens to the
left-hand fraction Bam Bam
okay ah now you get this thing
and then you get this thing now remember
horizontal or oblique asymptotes are all
about what happens to X when it gets
really really big positive or really
really big negative now tell me what is
happening to this thing for those kinds
of avenues when she said look at this
guy what's happening to it this guy vo
ha is just vanishing away you notice
that the denominator is getting huge the
numerator is just staying what it is so
this time might as well not be here yeah
so guess what you've got left
there's your oblique asymptote right
this thing becomes nothing which is why
you approach you approach because the
difference becomes nothing and then
that's your oblique asymptote so it's
not horizontal it's a bleak and the
reason why is because it's all about
that degree do you notice that but if
the degrees were the same like in the
first question we did ok they're gonna
grow together you're gonna grow together
but this time they don't grow together
like this x squared on the top has no
counterpart on the bottom so that's why
he takes over okay yeah intercepts
you've got the X intercepts that you can
just read off this numerator namely x
equals 1 and negative 1 I'll just write
plus or minus 1
that means I should be able to find a
y-intercept as well how do I find a wine
dessert substitute in x equals 0 and in
fact the original onion factorized form
makes that easiest watch there it is
that's that's me doing x equals 0 you
see that all my X terms just disappear
so you got minus 1 over minus 3 which
gives you
okay I've lined up all the Ducks I'm
gonna draw some axes now and put some
regional sometimes you just go that and
that's fine it's better duck laid up I
learn sooner or later okay
what am I going to put on here I want
him to features to add I've got the
vertical asymptotes the short answer is
yes however it's a bit like this the
reason why polynomial division is
worthwhile is because it will work every
single fingers every single time no
matter what kind of combination you have
you can divide through and immediately
polynomial division it's long right but
it works whereas any other technique
you've got to find what the oblique
asymptote maybe they only work this time
or that time or whatever degrees are in
so it's like do I want to learn five
different methods for a different year
so even though it's you know this is the
reason why by the way I'm quite happy to
advocate using synthetic division
because this question is not about
division it's about the oblique
asymptotes here's what the synthetic
division looks like for this you'll
laugh by how quickly I can do it there's
that so I just got one three three nine
eight there we go know what I just did
because you're not familiar with the
form but if you look closely at the
numbers see that one three and eight
they correspond to one two three and
eight right the 1 0 negative 1 up 1 0
and negative 1 because really what makes
a long division serve all is your
writing
all right and you're gonna do them so
many times over so much of space and
just take you forever
this is doing all the same computation
except it just strips out all the
unnecessary okay so anyway I can talk
about that another time if you like
where you can put up the video on us
okay luxury of eating exactly all right
i got i got the assassin taking us I've
got the Bleak asymptotes you should
watch out for that this is gonna be a
bit challenging battle kindergarten
I said label all my asymptotes so
there's 1 X plus 3 there's X equals 3
what else I got you I got a couple of
intercepts yeah and I've also got a
y-intercept which is 1/3 something like
that okay now here instead of as you saw
last time I mean it's actually a lot
easier for you if you got a pencil
because you can like shade and your
regions can look quite good okay but my
regions are kind of just turning into a
dog's breakfast so I just want you to
imagine the regions with me right can
you see my three factor lines can you
imagine them X minus one is gonna get it
through here X plus one is gonna go
through here and X minus three is gonna
interview someone to is that okay
now think you actually are going to
start down here you have to because how
many factors are there three and then
all these they always start off negative
so negative negative negative bring it
down yeah I'm gonna cross over from here
to here I'm gonna have to there's still
negative and one that's positive so when
you combine them when you share your
regions and get up wasn't it and then it
switches and then it switches one last
time
switch back and forth well if your
factors are linear like these are okay
then yes absolutely
because every time a single factor is
changing from negative to positive and
then the next single factors changing
from negative to positive which has that
flipping of that okay but sometimes I
mean I could give you something like
this if I made a denominator this okay
you can factorize that right what would
that our denominator become this is sum
of cubes okay now you have a look at
this now the whole point of sum of cubes
is that this gets factorized but this is
stuck and you can go and do your
discriminant on this and have no real
solutions
so therefore this thing right this is
one of the factors but it's not linear
is it it's a parabola right but that's
okay cuz think nobody operates
what's the leading coefficient it's one
that means it's positive definite okay
so guess what this factor is this factor
here no matter what number you throw it
is always going to be what is it so so
what does it contribute to the sign of
the whole thing answer it doesn't
contribute anything because it's always
a positive number
does that make sense so in this case you
should be on factorize down but if you
can't you can still work out what to do
that alright ready to draw the state I
know I'm gonna go negative positive
negative which makes sense cuz look at
where my intercepts are you see that
where it also gonna go all right what
about up here to the right of this issue
follow it goes negative positive
negative positive keep in mind I've got
these two asymptotes to approach so what
she's gonna happen I think I'm gonna get
ya this kind of shape right like you've
got to go up to that very classic to it
you gotta go okay if you tried to do
anything else if you try and do some
mapping down here you're not gonna go
check a big acetone you supposed to do
right and if you try and go yeah it's
not gonna work your slides won't let you